Drop what you're doing and stop Spider-Man
You, you, him, you, me
Welcome back everyone this will be my full
breakdown and Easter Eggs for Spider-Man
Across the Spider-Verse there were a billion
references a bunch of Cameo scenes to pretty
much every single version of Spider-Man from the
comics from all the previous movies even some of
the spin-off movies like the Venom movies as well
as all the Animated Series as well too you could
watch the movie a thousand times and still find
new stuff so if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos we're
still giving away tickets to the movie all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and just
leave your favorite Easter egg from the movie in
the comments careful for spoilers for the movie
if you haven't CDL because we'll be talking about
everything that happens just starting at the
beginning and working our way through shot by
shot talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments as
we go along the Sony title glitches the same way
it did during the first movie one of them is the
font from the Miles Morales original comic book
where he debuted the bubble effect they use here
they use it several times in the movie is called
the Kirby crackle they use it during the first
movie too it was just Jack Kirby's way in the
classic comics of animating cosmic energy they
also use it during the Marvel what if series 2.
there are a lot of similar tropes that they use
in what if that they used in this movie too with
the blend of live action elements and animated
elements like it's all Canon to the Multiverse
these are just other universes where everything
happens to be animated like in Doctor Strange
Multiverse of Madness the other Sony logos are
all meant to be versions from old Spider-Man TV
shows like the classic TV shows the classic comic
books their older real-life versions of the Sony
and Columbia Pictures logo 2 from black and white
like real world history when Columbia Pictures
started the same is true for the Marvel logo too
like they flash between several different variants
of the Marvel logo because there have been so many
other versions of Spider-Man movies as well as
Spider-Man comic books and Spider-Man TV shows
they're meant to be about 280 total different
versions of Spider-Man in the movie but only about
95 of them are actually official versions from the
comics and only a handful of those actually have
speaking lines these name tags are also based on
a combination of the comic book logos from the
different versions of Spider-Man in the movie
and the name tag convention from the first movie
when all the different versions were introducing
themselves retelling the same origin story like
let's do this one last time all right let's do
this one last time they even have a version of
the classic Marvel super Wars logo because some of
the plot mirrors the events of the classic Secret
Wars in the Multiverse there's also a rumor that
we're going to see some spider-verse characters
cross over in Avengers 6 secret orgs when they do
that in the MCU movies there are a bunch of MCU
crossover moments and scenes during this movie
too pretty much everybody had theories about
what might be in this movie and everyone wound
up being correct like the craziest theories all
wound up paying off in some small way during the
Lord and Miller producer titles it also flashes to
a real world classic code of arms version with a
bunch of real pictures of them making funny faces
the approved by the comics code Authority logo is
also taken from real life Comics it was used as a
symbol on comics for a governing body that deemed
things appropriate for Mass conception back in
the 1950s they were meant to be sort of like an
MPA AAA ratings agency like you rate movies rated
R like rated for adults or however it is in your
country in the United States Congress got really
upset with the quality of comics in the 1950s and
said it was polluting it was corrupting the youth
basically regulating comics in the movie you could
kind of think of the spider Force as being like
that but for the Multiverse like Spider-Man 2099
is deeming Miles Morales to be inappropriate in a
danger to the Multiverse so he needs to be either
locked up or need to somehow undo him becoming
Spider-Man the opening scene is also meant to
be very different in that the movie starts with
spider Gwen on her Earth showing her backstory
with a bunch of scenes incorporating the events of
the entire movie like she basically tells you how
the entire movie is going to play out here in this
opening scene her voiceover starts with her saying
let's do things differently because it is very
different both in what she's talking about the way
they animate it and just thematically in the movie
from the earlier introduction scenes during the
first movie it's also meant to flow with the whole
idea in the movie that Nexus events like changing
the Canon events they call it canon in the movie
but it's another word for Nexus event it's like
the TVA during the Loki series trying to stop
Nexus events people from changing the timeline
in ways that will cause the destruction of that
universe or cause very bad things to happen and
during the movie Gwen changes history on her Earth
with Miles Morales help her father Captain Stacy
winds up quitting his job and therefore doesn't
wind up being killed like he's supposed to be in
the cannon and it does not lead to the destruction
of her Universe like Spider-Man 2099 thinks that
it will so they're basically starting the movie
by saying it's okay to do things differently and
it's meant to be the theme of the entire movie
like Miles Morales is okay existing and it's
not going to cause the Multiverse to collapse the
animation Style on her Earth is mostly in pastels
the music is a big part of her life so the Beat
of the Music the colors all change every time her
mood changes so that's why every time when she's
in scenes on her Earth all the things around her
start shifting around during this movie just in
general she's meant to be a much bigger character
than the first movie I'd argue that she's like the
second main lead because the things that she does
drive as a plot just as much as what Miles Morales
is doing during the movie A lot of the scenes are
actually things that happen in the future of
the movie so it's almost like they're taking
her narrating her backstory but it's after the
movie takes place and they just put this at the
beginning of the movie when she says that miles is
not the only one who's had it hard that's because
her origin story involves something similar where
she's blamed wrongly for the death of her Peter
Parker just like Spider-Man 2099 wrongly blames
miles for the death of his Peter Parker her band
makes fun of her calling her Def Leppard because
of her crazy long drum solo while she's narrating
this early scene on her Earth she also goes to
the Visions high school that Miles goes to on
his Earth which she pretended to go to briefly
when she was trying to figure out what was going
on on his Earth the 1990 Banner behind them is
a reference to the Peter Parker Spider-Man comic
that ran from 1990 to 1998 because she like Miles
Morales is one of the newer versions of Spider-Man
who weren't created until much more recently in
the comics one of the main things that happened
during that run in particular was Ben Reilly was
really big during that during the movie Ben Reilly
Scarlet Spider is played by Andy Samberg who
plays it mostly for comedy like he's a super Emo
character that always speaks this really overly
dramatic kind of hammy internal monologue like
you would read in comic book thought bubbles well
I heard about the new Spider-Man movie figured I
would odd dish maybe catch that part in my web
are you just redoing the same monologue that
Kirsten Dunst did like 10 years ago uh yeah aren't
you just redoing the exact same Spider-Man movie
from 10 years ago the reason her Earth is number
65 is because the original Gwen Stacy debuted in
The Amazing Spider-Man comics in the year 1965.
the other apropos Easter egg here too is that her
band's name are the Mary Janes because in the
original Amazing Spider-Man comics Gwen Stacy
was Spider-Man's original love interest Mary Jane
had a brief Cameo scene in that same year in 1965
when Gwen Stacy debuted but Mary Jane didn't
really become a big character until a couple
years later in 1967 so she came along a little
bit later even though if you look like the entire
history of Spider-Man comics they've been writing
her as Spider-Man's love interest for a longer
in duration but technically Gwen Stacy came first
her comments about never finding the right band to
be in is a reference to her own spider Force team
that she puts together at the end of the movie to
go save Miles Morales made up of the team from the
first movie in addition to Spider-Man India spider
bite and Hobie brown spider Punk if you're not
familiar with spider Gwen's origin story this is
also based on the comics too her version of Peter
Parker actually became a version of the lizard
taking his serum and wound up leading to his own
death like he caused his own death if he sounded
familiar her Peter Parker was actually voiced by
Jack Quake very small voice over Cameo scene in
Gwen's relationship with her father I think is
also meant to be a metaphor like a template for
how Miles Morales relationship with Spider-Man
2099 will ultimately play out where first her
father other blames Spider Woman for the death
of Peter Parker but eventually once he learns the
truth he comes around on her I think Spider-Man
2099 will eventually come around on Miles Morales
by the end of Spider-Man beyond the spider verse
there's a real quick blink and you'll miss it Jay
Jonah Jameson Cameo scene voiced by JK Simmons he
has a bunch of Cameo scenes in different universes
like it's always JK Simmons coming back as an
alternate version of Jay Jonah Jameson and most of
them are closer to the version that you see during
Spider-Man no way home in the MCU where the Daily
Bugle is more of like a online news organization
it is more of like a TV pundit the only one that
we see that's actually still The Daily Bugle
newspaper and that version of the character is
actually in Lego Spider-Man's Universe don't worry
I'll talk about him when we get to that part of
the movie because that was a pretty cool Easter
egg her father Captain Stacy is played by Shea
Winningham he's the alternate universe version of
the same character that Denis Leary plays in The
Amazing Spider-Man Andrew Garfield movies who both
wind up having Cameo scenes later he also noticed
during the movie that she goes from wearing
the ballet shoes to wearing the Chuck Taylors
that belonged to spider Punk while she's still
heading to stop the vulture Jay Jonah Jameson also
starts talking about how the Sinister Six in this
universe is starting to call the shots take over
in her Universe a lot of sinister six characters
that also show up during the movie two different
versions from the classic comics from the TV
shows and the live action versions too they're
attacked by an alternate universe version of the
vulture from a Leonardo da Vinci inspired Universe
where everything is old-timey it looks like it's
based on parchment like he's a parchment-based
person when he moves around the weapons he uses
all based on Leonardo da Vinci like technology
he's also Italian like Da Vinci was when she's
fighting him Gwen makes a Mario Kart Super Mario
reference I believe the vultures criminal number
like 99 here reference to Amazing Spider-Man 99
which was a Gwen stacy-like Adventure where things
played in a slightly similar type of way but for
Spider-Man most the time when you see numbers on
screen and movies like this there are references
to something so let me know in the comments what
you think these or references too when she jokes
about his cousin here I believe this is meant to
be a version of Isaac Newton who wasn't actually
Da Vinci's cousin in real life just another
scientific genius from a couple hundred years
later in history Spider-Man 2099 enters from the
spider Force to capture him played by Oscar Isaac
who's also Moon Knight in the MCU and even though
I didn't say it obviously spider Gwen is played
by Haley Steinfeld who is also a version of Kate
Bishop there are many many actors in this movie
playing characters who are either also characters
inside the MCU live action movies or are playing
the same versions from those live-action MCU
movies maybe someday we'll see a live action
version of Spider-Man 2099 that would be really
cool the only thing that they've changed since the
Spider-Man into the spider-verse post credit scene
about his character is just make his character
model seem way more monstrous like he's way bigger
and way more hardcore looking his real name in the
comics is Miguel O'Hara he's from the year 2099
in that version of New York City has become Nueva
York he works for alcamax which they referenced
in the movies several times and the accident
that turned him into Spider-Man was more like a
mutation so his powers are a little bit different
too like he has an actual spider bite ability
where it can actually paralyze villains which
he tries to do to the vulture before the police in
this universe stop him he doesn't have those hairs
that help him stick to walls and stick upside down
like all the other versions of Spider-Man but he's
got these hardcore talents which he uses to rip
into things his web shooters are also energy based
Annie has a cape that he can form that will help
him glide through the air he's the one who made
the web wear wrist watches like all the technology
in the movie is from his Universe they reference
the blue panther which is a black panther joke the
Caped clue seder which is a Batman joke making a
DC reference like the Caped Crusader dark Garfield
Macho Libre because he's hispanic like Nacho Libre
or Lucha Libre when he narrates his origin story
there's a cover from Spider-Man 2099 number one in
real life all the comic book covers are usually
from real life with a few exceptions like Miles
Morales has done with his symbol from the first
movie in some of the scenes on the comic book
covers are scenes directly from the movie but
like you see all these other comic book covers
denoting the other characters from the first movie
usually all of his cut twos are also done as comic
book panels too and usually when they flew through
the pages of all these different comic books when
people are narrating their origin stories or they
have different scenes like this they are Pages
directly copied from real life like you could
actually open up a comic book and read these pages
when he starts yelling at her he references the
events of the first movie with kingpin's collider
exploding because as he reveals later he knows
everything that's happened his whole reason for
making the spider Forge team was to clean up the
tears in the Multiverse the spider verse so to
speak like the Nexus events cause as a result of
the first movie The Spider force is basically like
the TVA but a bunch of versions of Spider-Man
doing it they even literally use the same
depiction of the multiverses different timelines
that they do during the Loki series they explained
during the first movie that the spider that
bit miles turning him in to Spider-Man was from
Earth 42 a different universe and it led to this
domino effect where more and more Multiverse tears
Nexus events started happening in all of reality
became threatened he also references the events
of Spider-Man no way home and Doctor Strange's
spells when he calls Tom Holmes Spider-Man the
nerd from Earth 19999 and Gwen makes more jokes
about Doctor Strange being a bad Doctor Who maybe
shouldn't practice medicine part of the reason
why they're doing this is because a long time ago
there was Marvel TV and Marvel Studios like it was
two completely different groups of people in the
Marvel TV people canonized the live-action stuff
is earth 19999 when they did the first Spider-Man
into the spider-verse movie They said that Peter B
Parker was from Earth 616 which is the traditional
Marvel comic book universe but in the last few
Marvel movies Kevin feige has been saying that
the MCU is earth616 so I think the larger reason
why they say that MCU is Earth 1999 in this movie
is just because they did that in the first movie
They said that Peter B Parker's universe was 616
instead of the MCU it's not like they're trying
to change Canon or anything like that originally
Earth 616 was meant to be the universe of the
official Marvel Comics like the main timeline
in the Marvel comic book universe so they wanted
to say in the first movie that Peter B Parker was
meant to be the original comic book Spider-Man
when he mentions Hammer space that's actually a
spider ham reference it's where he keeps all of
his hammers like his giant comic bookie devices
that he just whips out on a dime because they're
so huge like where would he pull them out from
Is His interdimensional Infinite Space you also
notice throughout the movie and this is true for
a lot of characters different scenes is they'll
have little notes and thought bubbles that you
see like they were written in an actual comic
Lila is his digital assistant kind of like his
version of Jarvis or Friday played by Jenny
slate she was also in the post-credits scene
for the first movie then they introduced the new
version of Jessica Drew Spider Woman played by
israe she's super pregnant like Jessica Drew was
in the comics they have a similar type of custom
it's a little bit different except she rides
a motorcycle she uses in combat there was a
reference to Jessica Drew in the first movie but
it was the version from miles morales's original
universe and it was a slightly different version
of the character just in general they allowed Gwen
to come back to the spider force with them after
they see she's about to be arrested by her father
and things are going terribly in her Universe She
also reveals her identity to her Father which sets
off the change in the continuity of the Canon of
her Universe creating a Nexus event that allows
him to survive because he quits the police force
creating proof that they can change things from
the candidate like they can create these kinds
of Nexus events and it won't destroy the entire
Multiverse so Miles Morales does not need to
be locked up for the rest of all time they had
the rest of the opening titles and the drawings
this time were all meant to be from Miles Morales
original art style like he drew these depicting
the events of the first movie a couple of months
go by and we pick up with him in his second year
at high school but he's still about 15 years old
during the events of this movie it's meant to have
been about a year since the events of the first
movie this time he gets his own version of that
one last time speech narrating his backstory with
a montage of the previous movie and his adventures
since the first movie with jokes about how he's
doing great but it's meant to be ironic compared
to the other versions of Spider-Man because he's
kind of botching his saves like he takes down
to those he usually catches them but he causes
so much collateral damage because he's still
learning how to be Spider-Man even though he's
gotten much better since the events of the first
movie the number 42 that shows up here is another
reference to that original Spider that bit him
from Universe 42 it's also the number on miles's
Brooklyn Jersey which is a Jackie Robinson
Brooklyn Dodgers reference another cool MCU
connection is the Jackie Robinson was played by
black panther Chadwick Boseman in the movie 42
which also starred Harrison Ford who is now the
recast version of Thunderbolt Ross in the MCU
this time his comic reads number two to represent
year two like it's his second movie and he gets a
couple other comment covers later in the movie
and the number goes up each time he gets a new
comic book while his narrating his intro scene
they also cut it with the scene of his parents
meeting his school counselor talking about college
admissions I fully expect that he will stay within
the New York City area like the larger New York
City area because he wants to go to Princeton
which is close enough by that he could continue to
have Adventures as Spider-Man in the New York City
area and they'll just continue making animated
spider-verse movies after Spider-Man beyond the
spiderverse even though right now they're talking
about doing live action Miles Morales movies I
just did a video about that so I'll link in the
description below but they did confirm that they
are developing live-action Miles Morales stuff if
he couldn't tell his school counselors played by
Rachel Dratch her name has Webb in it like more
spider puns they also cut the intro scenes with
the spots debut trying to rob the bodega in a
funny way the spot played by Jason Schwartzman
he's meant to be the real main villain of this
movie and the beyond the spider-verse movie He's
also based on the comic book version of the
spot named Jonathan own within the context of
the movie he was a scientist working on Kingpin
super collider when it blew up giving him his
powers he's also the person who brought that
spider from Earth 42 that bit miles so that's
why he says later in the movie you created me and
I created you which is also a line of dialogue
inspired by the Michael Keaton Batman 1989 movie
with the Joker you idiot you made me I made you
first spot also says that he was the same
scientist in the cafeteria in the first movie
that they hit with the bagel which they had that
funny animation like the emote that said Bagel
they do that for a lot of the different emotes
in the movie when characters do things it's a
very comic Booky way of depicting sounds in the
movie or actions the whole idea here is that he
just starts as this Petty criminal like he's
only turned to Crime because he can't get a
real job like he tried to get a real job and can't
because he looks like this he's not meant to be
particularly evil just misguided then as he slowly
realizes how he can use his powers to change the
Multiverse and he feels slighted by Miles Morales
who calls him a villain of the week spider-gwen
also calls him a villain of the week he grows to
hate miles thinking that miles is responsible from
taking his life from him like all these bad things
were happening to him and his miles his fault for
some reason and by the end of the movie threatens
to destroy all of reality which is a little bit
like the beyonders during the more recent version
of Secret Wars in the comics like he's going to
collapse like destroy the entire Multiverse
then remake it the way that he wants it to be
when he's trying to rob the bodega here at the
beginning the owner Pepe orsco is actually played
by Ziggy Marley the son of musician Bob Marley
in real life there was another joke about money
in Miles Morales Universe during the first movie
like they had crazy high prices so I think the
idea is the inflation is just out of control in
miles's Universe I couldn't quite tell whose face
was on the money in his universe so let me know
in the comments if you think you know who this
is during their fight here as they're walking
around the store you also notice the magazine
rack is full of magazines with Miles Morales on
the cover depicting his adventures in the past
year miles is correct when he says it is weird
that people call them ATM machines because ATM
literally stands for automatic teller machine so
it's like saying automatic teller machine machine
and the joke is meant to foreshadow the Spider-Man
India joke where he calls chai chai tea like chai
means tea so you're calling it TT basically for
a cup of chai with my my auntie I love chai tea
what did you just say shy DJI means D bro you're
saying DD would I ask you for a coffee coffee
with room for cream cream no no you also notice in
the bodega and this is also true for pretty much
every other food or drink item in Miles Morales
universe everything has generic names like the
paper towels are called wipe his energy drink is
literally called Energy drink this also probably
for copyright reasons too when miles starts
narrating the adventures that he's had in the
past and they start doing the Montage of different
villains this one seems like a monster it could be
a version of Tombstone because the other ones are
from the comics too he fought Frogman who is from
the comics they featured him during She-Hulk I
think this one is meant to be one of the other
Prowlers for the comics there were several others
that wore the mantle besides his uncle Aaron Davis
was probably just one of the other ones he fought
a version of Craven on his Earth there's a live
action craving the hunter movie coming later this
year with Aaron Taylor-Johnson it's connected to
the Venom movies and morbius it'll also be rated
R when they show the Montage of the new suits that
he's creating that he's designing here these are
all meant to be based on comic book designs in his
Universe he says his Aunt May moved to Florida I'm
assuming because he's helping her in a Spider-Man
costume she also continued to give him access to
Peter Parker's Spider-Man Lair there because they
never addressed that during the movie so either
she moved to Florida with her or they just left
it there for him to use he hosts Jeopardy and if
you notice here all the categories are Spider-Man
references the baby powder apology joke is based
on something that happened in real life it was
a huge debacle that was discovered at Johnson
Johnson baby powder product was causing cancer
in infants this is a real thing that happened
and they had to make this huge settlement the
celebrity endorsement fail is also a bit of a
crypto joke I think because a bunch of celebrities
are now being clowned on and part of a huge
lawsuit because of how crypto tanked and a ton
of people lost piles of money and a lot of it came
through a lot of these celebrity endorsements you
also notice in the YouTube comments on his apology
video Someone commented I hear the powder was made
from actual babies which sounds very much like a
typical YouTube comment you get a lot of those on
videos like a lot of really weird stuff there's
also the whole concept of the YouTube apology
video which is like a huge Trope in real life now
you're almost not a real YouTuber if you haven't
made a bunch of apology videos about something
his YouTube channel is named the mic drop where
he posts these Spider-Man videos of himself
Miss Marvel and the MCU also has her own YouTube
channel called sloth baby Productions where she
posts her Avengers fan movies that she makes at
home he made an apology video later also for his
lame mustache that he tried to grow which is like
a very teenager kind of thing to do like look I
can grow a mustache but it's a terrible mustache
I'm not sure who this giant robot is supposed
to be but I think it's based on something from
the comics the new twist that he talks about with
his Spider-Man Venom ability is the spider Stinger
that's also a comic book thing it's his electrical
shock ability he used it during the first movie
it's just gotten better at it since then in Hobie
brown spider Punk also teaches them how to use it
in a more powerful way too it allows him to absorb
electrical energy and redirect it which he used
it to destroy Spider-Man 2099's force field and
drain the energy from his suit and Blasting with
it early Theory too he might be able to use this
Venom Stinger ability to de-power the spot because
the spot is essentially an energy based villain
it's just Dark Matter energy in miles's Universe
they show his version of Jay Jonah Jameson yelling
about him being terrible just like MCU Spider-Man
when he fantasizes about telling his parents his
secret identity and says maybe in another Universe
they'd accept me that actually winds up happening
in Earth 42 where that version of his mother is
fine with it since the events of the first movie
he's added spider Gwen and a bunch of the other
characters like pretty much the events of the
entire first movie to that mural where he was
bitten by the spider originally when he's trying
to take the spot down one of the little kids is
also wearing a Miles Morales Halloween mask which
is a reference to his Peter Parker Spider-Man
Halloween costume from the first movie sold to
him in the Stanley Cameo scene the other funny
detail here and then later in the movie when he's
traveling with the cakes is that you notice that
all the people around them could not be bothered
could not care less that there are two super
powered individuals fighting in front of them like
nope there's just another normal day in New York
City in the Brooklyn area and when he sees Genki
he's playing the Spider-Man PS4 game but on a PS5
like it's a PS5 controller which is funny for a
couple reasons because Spider-Man PS4 has a cameo
in this movie he's Canon to the universe it's kind
of like the Super Mario movie with Mario playing
games on a Nintendo console he's wearing the Miles
Morales edition Nike sneakers with the Air Jordan
sneakers Nike made those in real life I think the
directors wore them to the premiere and I think
you might be able to buy them in real life he also
jokes about not being miles's man in the chair
that's an MCU Ned leaves joke who calls himself
Tom Holland MCU Spider-Man's man in the chair also
in the comics and in the new PS5 Spider-Man 2 game
Genki becomes miles's new man in the chair helping
him out on missions I also just did a video for
that new Spider-Man 2 trailer so I'll link that
Below in the description too when he's trying to
give him reasons for not helping him out he also
references the spider signal in a bunch of other
Spider-Man details from the comics and things that
they've done in the MCU movies as well one of the
other things he uses here in this scene too is his
camouflage ability not only does it render him
invisible to the naked eye it also works against
other spider people's Spidey senses like spider
Gwen's spidey sense doesn't go off when he's right
in front of her face the counselor's speech about
capturing every person's universe is a metaphor
for the spider Society capturing Multiverse
villains the comments about having your cake
and eating it too is a reference to the two cakes
that he tries to make later and also foreshadowing
for at the end of the next movie like literally
the end of part two beyond the spider verse
they'll save the Multiverse and miles will be
allowed to continue being Spider-Man and have his
relationship with spider Gwen they're basically
telling you in this movie at the very beginning
how everything is going to play out if you're
looking at the clues the joke about the B in
Spanish is that he's half Hispanic so his mother
expects him to speak perfect Spanish Technically
she's Puerto Rican so when she snaps her fingers
yelling at him that's why it makes a little Puerto
Rican flag lag emote when they resume their
fight the portals take them back to Kingpin
super collider where he finishes explaining his
backstory and his relationship with Miles there
are more references to his father dying too which
is a big theme in the movie as part of the whole
Uncle Ben Captain Stacy death Montage later the
idea that they're all predestined to die but miles
wants to change events so that his father lives
in his Universe Gwen's father living proves that
later in her universe as well when he saves his
father here at the beginning he also saves him
in the same way that the original Peter Parker
saved miles at the beginning of the first movie
when they met for the first time landing on the
exact same platform like the kind of Speed Run
replay the events of the first movie in this
scene here when the spot starts narrating his
backstory and what happened with the spider from
Earth 42 the character with the braids who's in
the class about to be bitten by that spider is
that universe's version of Miles Morales which
we see at the end of the movie they're basically
trying to say that that spider was about to turn
him into a version of Spider-Man which is why
his universe first turned into like the Back to
the Future 2 dark version of the universe because
there was no Spider-Man to try and stop all these
criminals that's why Spider-Man 2099 and a lot of
the other characters are trying to make files feel
bad like it's his fault that things are going
badly then the spot figures out how his powers
really work with portals to the Multiverse and
he starts exploring the different universes with
a whole bunch of Cameo scenes and Easter eggs
the very first one he goes to is based on the
classic Comics animated like the original Jack
Kirby Comics the next one is the Lego Universe
with Lego Spider-Man who they reference is one of
the most powerful best versions of Spider-Man on
the team this is also meant to just generally be
a reference to Lord and Miller's Lego movies that
he did with Chris Pratt they made all the Lego
movies I think they also worked on the Batman Lego
Movie 2 which was kind of like a spin-off during
this scene there are a bunch of other details too
like it's a much longer scene there's another
JK Simmons J Jonah Jameson Cameo scene but this
version is working at a Daily Bugle like it's an
actual newspaper like the comics and this version
of Peter Parker started to work looking for him
the headline in the background about doc Ox still
being at large I think is another Spider-Man 2
reference because there were headlines similar
in that movie the newspaper is called the Lego
news which is weird because in their Universe
shouldn't they think that they're normal and not
Lego Creations maybe in their Universe Lego is
just like a random company that happens to own
the newspaper and not a company that makes Lego
toys the other funny detail here from the Lego
movies that they borrow is that when he contacts
Spider-Man 2099 he makes the beep beep sound with
his own voice just to give it that homemade Vibe
kind of like the original Lego movies like someone
crafted this and they're making their own movie
with Legos when the spot says the power of the
Multiverse in the power of my hand that's also
a reference to Dr octopus's line in Spider-Man
2 the power of the Sun in the palm of my hand
he also gets a cameo scene later in the movie
that I'll talk about because it's a little bit
meta the way that they do it then he travels
to the live-action Venom movie Universe in
Mrs Chen's Bodega stealing a Venom mint from her
like stealing gum which is also merch based on Tom
Hardy's Venom I love the way they're blending the
live action the animated elements it's all Canon
through the Multiverse they did the same thing
during what if like this is all Canon to the
MCU it just happens to be in different universes
that are animated not live action when they go to
the party I'm not sure which card game these kids
are playing let me know if you think you spotted
it on his way home with the cakes he fights the
armadillo who is from the comics the train fight
is also another reference to Spider-Man 2 which
they parodied in the first movie you notice the
criminal of these stops from stealing the shoes
is stealing a bunch of Air Jordans that's the
brand of shoe that he's wearing like his special
custom Miles Morales edition Air Jordans they show
the mural of his uncle on the roof foreshadowing
the scene at the end on Earth 42 where it's of
his father instead while his father is giving
a very ominous speech about his future always
being around being very dependable I will never
leave you I will always help you the other funny
detail here too is when miles is talking about his
friends that left town quote unquote he's talking
about his team from the first movie he still calls
spider Gwen Gowanda and when they introduce them
later he still calls her gwanda his bedroom is
filled with all kinds of Pop Culture references
like he reads the true Tales of Spider-Man comics
which are based on the in-universe adventures of
that original Peter Parker the cover is also
based on the original cover of Amazing Fantasy
number 15 first appearance of Spider-Man there's
also a deleted scene here too we found out about
in the early versions of the movie Miles Morales
is meant to be an anime fan who collects my hero
Academia action figures that was supposed to be
a Deku action figure in place of the one that
spider Gwen messes with I'm guessing they swapped
it in the final version just for copyright reasons
like they couldn't get approval or whatever
to use Deku from my hero this is also a nice
toy collector joke too like she she takes it out
of the package ruining its mint condition in his
scrapbook of drawings of her he's also got a bus
ticket that they use to get from alcamax when he
met her for the first time the book that he's
reading here the fire next time is also a real
life book about civil rights her sweater the Chuck
Taylor she's wearing were given to her by spider
Punk who's become her Mentor since she joined the
spider force a few months ago when he says her
hair's gotten Pinker remember the whole idea is
that her colors change based on her mood the pink
shift is because she likes miles she's there to
try and track down the spot for the spider Forge
but she wanted to see miles briefly the way they
talk about it later too it sounds like Spider-Man
2099 had always planned at some point to capture
Miles Morales and just imprisoned him for the rest
of his life and they just forced spider-gwen to
be quiet about it this whole time like no you're
not allowed to visit him you're not allowed to
talk to him about it during the Montage of them
catching up when they say the woman's purse she
also leaves a note that says from your friendly
neighborhood Spider Woman which is a reference to
Friendly neighborhoods Spider-Man in the comics
you also notice that this universe version of
FedEx is called Red X I'm assuming they couldn't
get permission from FedEx to use their logo in
the movie that happens all the time that's also
the reason why they use a lot of the generic names
for a lot of these products once you start scoping
out the spot the building he's in has a billboard
on top that says all the O's always over the place
which is a reference to his spot portals being
all over the Multiverse the bank that they're
on also feels like a reference like a nod to the
bank fight scene in Spider-Man 2. she explains the
part of the Canon story relative to Gwen Stacy's
of the Multiverse they always fall for a version
of Spider-Man and it always ends badly him saying
there's a first for everything is also a reference
to them being able to change the spider-verse
Canon change timelines create Nexus events without
it destroying all of reality remember it's all
about having your cake and eating it too that's
the way they're gonna end Spider-Man beyond the
spider verse he will have his cake and eat it
too I'll let you guess what cake is a metaphor
for when is my mother says she looks old enough
to vote that's a joke about all the actors in the
movie that are voicing characters being way older
than the characters they play in the movie like
for instance Haley Steinfeld who voices spider
Gwen is in her 20s as well as shamik Moore who's
in his late 20s in Miles Morales it's meant to be
like 15 during the movie when Jessica Drew later
starts talking about hanging out with people who
were bad in her past or things going badly in
her past she's referencing Jessica Drew's comic
book history with the high evolutionary when
he was still Herbert Edgar Windham before he
became High evolutionary she was also brainwashed
by Hydra when she was younger we go to Spider-Man
India's Universe where his version of New York
City is called Moon Batten which is a reference
to Manhattan he's also played by Karen Sony who is
also do Pinder in the Deadpool movies he's coming
back during Deadpool 3-2 so another actor who's a
different character in The live-action MCU movies
the gag with his character is that he's super
good at being Spider-Man his life seems perfect
compared to all the problems that both miles and
Gwen have had in their lives miles all sorts of
glitching out in his Universe because he doesn't
have the risk device to prevent that yet there's
all kinds of jokes that are specific to Indian
culture like he uses a Latitude device he makes
jokes about the crazy traffic everywhere which
you could say is common to most major cities in
the Far East he's also Indian Miss Marvel
is Pakistani so two completely different
cultures like a lot of the others his comic book
cover isn't from the real life Marvel Comics but
Spider-Man India is from Marvel Comics this is
his version of Green Goblin they have the chai
tea joke paying off the ATM joke from earlier this
is his universe's version of Gwen Stacy and her
father who is the police captain they also have a
joke about the British museum saying that this is
where the British stole all our stuff which is
a real life reference to British colonialism in
India they also kind of reference that during the
Miss Marvel series too he also makes the Eat Pray
Love joke about an American the spot coming to
India and co-opting the culture coming to steal
something from India the when the spot says that
he's doing this because miles made him feel empty
I think it's meant to be this cautionary tale like
a metaphor for miles of story with Spider-Man 2099
and ultimately miles will wind up stopping the
Spot Not only by using his Venom Stinger belly
by like sucking a lot of the energy out of spot
but also talking him down in a way that Spider-Man
2099 is not doing during this movie miles will see
spots side of things and start to feel bad for him
and try to help him out in a way that Spider-Man
2099 did not do for Miles during this movie they
introduced Hobie brown spider Punk who is from
the comics he's played by Daniel caluya who's also
in the Black Panther movie more live-action MCU
actors coming as spider-verse people one of the
big things about the animation for his character
is that he says in the movie that he hates the
idea of consistency so his character is animated
in a very inconsistent way so like sometimes he's
black and white sometimes it's in color sometimes
he's in a bunch of different types of colors he's
basically meant to be a walking version of the
punk movement which is very Counter Culture he
says he hates the idea of teams so he's kind of
like a force of chaos why talking during the movie
during the next scene when spot Powers up with
this dark matter miles sees the spot's memories
and his plans for the Multiverse like I said his
plans are similar to the beyonder's plans in the
more recent secret words with him unmaking the
Multiverse when their team is saving everyone
to this is sort of a preview for what their team
is going to feel like during Spider-Man beyond
the spider-verse because most of these people are
on that team at the end of the movie miles save
Spider-Man India's Captain Stacy version earning
his respect but it also creates a Nexus event
threatening the destruction of their Universe
because according to the Canon he was supposed to
die Jessica Drew brings a bunch of other versions
of Spider-Man to try and stop the Nexus event this
is a version of the white Fantastic Four future
foundation suit but it's a Spider Woman this one
with the jacket seems like he's based on the
Last Stand version of Spider-Man the six armed
Spider-Man is based on Max Bourne who's from the
distant future who's part of an organization kind
of like this they call the time Spinners they're
like the T BBA but with a bunch of versions of
Spider-Man this one in the armor is based on the
spider armor Mark III they go back to Spider-Man
2099's universe and show his comic it's a scene
directly from the movie not from the comics
because it's from Miles morales's comic when the
pages are flipping though those pages are directly
from the Spider-Man 2099 Comics they're a couple
major versions of Spider-Man from the comics that
they highlight in the lobby here but there are
many many of them that were created just brand
new for the movie that you might not recognize
this one is a female version of spider UK before
it zooms out there are like 10 different versions
on the left it seems like there's a version of
MCU Spider-Man kind of hard to tell because of
the YouTube compression making it super blurry
talking to a version of the Canadian Spider-Man
next to them is the velocity suit talking to what
looks like the topi Maguire Spider-Man then way in
the back there's a version of the classic red and
blue suit just like the regular classic suit from
the original comics with another black suit that
might be a version of the anti-ox suit all on the
right it looks like the classic iron spider red
suit talking to the electro proof suit and another
black suit that's a little too blurry to see which
black suit it is then on the far right there's
one peeking around the corner that's another red
armor suit that looks kind of like a version of
the classic iron spider suit then slowly zooming
out a little bit at a time because there's so
many versions here in this first frame it seems
like Earth 916211 Spider-Man who just wore a suit
that was similar to this behind him I can't tell
who this female Yellow variant is there was a
yellow variant of the classic suit in the PS4
game that looked kind of like this behind her
seems like a version of Spider-Girl wearing a
variant suit from The Amazing Spider-Man 1000
they were from an unknown reality during that
this is the black and gold bulletproof Mark
II spider armor suit talking to what looks
like the Bruce Banner Spider-Man variant like
the Hulk who became a version of Spider-Man
and just had a white and blue costume like this
in the middle here featured very prominently is
Spider-Man from the PS4 game talking to Ben Riley
in a version of his ultimate costume in the lower
left hand corner I'm not sure which one this red
and blue symbol is but it seems like a variant
of the Velocity suit to the right of the yellow
and black suit seems like a version of the aim
Spider-Man who had been brainwashed by them then
when you zoom out a little more these two behind
them seem like versions of Jessica Drew and behind
her is another version of Jessica Drew in the red
and white suit like a couple different variants
of Jessica Drew zoom out a little more this is
steampunk spider girl named Mabel Riley talking
to another massive Peter Parker variant in a basic
red and blue suit on the left is spider cop behind
him seems like the manga verse Spider-man these
two girls are spinnerette who's a variant of Mary
Jane Parker that gets powers and her daughter with
Peter Parker named Annie Mae Parker further to
the right there's what looks like a version of the
fear itself suit it's not exactly like fear itself
but it's pretty close the blue suit seems like the
Spider-Man Fantastic Four suit the classic one not
the future foundation suit that was white zoom out
again you see the bombastic bag band next to
him I believe is a variant of Flash Thompson
Spider-Man from the comics wearing the Midtown
High letterman jacket this one above them seems
like the classic spider armor version over on the
right there's another yellow and black variant of
what seems like the anti-ox suit on the far right
this red and black version seems like a variant of
superior Spider-Man above him the glowing yellow
and black suit is another video game suit I can't
tell exactly which one this is this is werewolf
Spider-Man pretty easy to spot above them seems
like a version of Spider-Man negative next to him
the all blue Spider-Man seems like another variant
of spider cop the chunky Spider-Man next to him
seems like another version of Earth X Spiderman
then when they all try to Dogpile Miles Morales
like they all start going at him they're in this
exact same area and most of the ones that are
going after him are the ones that I just talked
about that were sitting around casually this is
Anya Corazon this is superior Spider-Man this is
six armed Spider-Man who grabs him with all of his
arms along with a version of the classic spider
armor this is one of the newer spider armor
suits it could also be the 4 fortnite version
of Spider-Man 2. this one wearing the business
suit is Dapper Spider-Man who's actually based
on fan art and cosplay like not all the versions
I think in this are meant to be Spider-Man from
the comics the movies of the games some of them
are from real life fan art which seems very much
in the tone of the spider-verse movies like some
of the variants are going to be the fan fiction
versions of Spider-Man then this isn't meant
to be MCU Spider-Man Tom Holland this is still
PS4 Spider-Man the same red variant next to him
in what looks like a suit from the later Secret
Wars event this is Kane over on the left for those
of you hoping that Kane would be in here there's
also spider monkey up top I believe this is a new
variant wearing the tracksuit in the regular shoes
all the others are ones that I just mentioned that
were sitting around previously this is the Manga
versus Spider-Man again trying to NAB him there's
some people that feel like they saw a version of
PS1 Spider-Man in here there's a version of cyborg
Spider Woman they did the Peter parked car from
the spider-verse comics it's a living version of
a spidermobile created by Stan Lee in the classic
Spider-Man comics and then sold as merch like you
could buy this toy Ben Reilly Scarlet Spider is
played by Andy Samberg the joke being that he's
super emo he speaks his internal monologue which
is overly serious and super dramatic like you
would read in one of his comic books the spider
horse is called Widow he is from the comics from
an old west Universe the reason the horse has
Spider-Man Powers is because he was also bit
by that same radioactive spider that gave his
owner Powers whose name is web Slinger when they
go to the Multiverse prisons there are tons of
canvas there's so much stuff here it's going to
take like five more times watching the movie to
spot them all this is a version of Craven this is
a villain named Boomerang from the comics this is
a version of Kingpin wearing a cowboy hat there's
a Doctor Octopus with actual Octopus arms this is
more like the PS4 version of the character this
one in the armor is more like the female Doctor
Octopus from the first movie this is Moose stereo
which is a moose version of Mysterio from spider
Ham's Universe this is a female Mysterio they
just call it Mysterio they have a bunch of video
game versions of Spider-Man like this one seems
like it's based on the very first Marvel video
game ever which was a Spider-Man game back in the
early 80s this is obviously Spider-Man PS4 from
that video game with a voice over Cameo from Yuri
lowenthal typeface is an actual villain from the
Spider-Man comics his real name was Gordon Thomas
they have a version of the Rhino who's just a
regular rhinoceros then they have a Donald Glover
Cameo scene as the MCU version of the prowler from
the main Tom Hall and Spider-Man movies like
after the events of Spider-Man homecoming he
got the armor and became full Prowler there
was even a deleted scene with a live-action
Miles Morales in the MCU so hopefully they'll
pay that off at some point spider Punk and Gwen
both say that they're the ones that caught him
and it happened recently one of the reasons why
he's so important to Miles Morales character to
is because in real life maseross was created by
Brian Michael Bendis after he saw Donald Glover
on the Community TV show wearing a Spider-Man
t-shirt and it inspired him to create the Miles
Morales character so Donald Glover is basically
responsible for Miles Morales existing in real
life then he meets the spider bite character
she's from a universe that's like the world of
Ready Player one where everyone lives mostly in
a game with avatars when she shows her real body
in her home Universe it looks like she's using a
psvr headset too this is a Sony movie so they want
that Sony product placement everywhere they can
get it like all the Playstations you can see in
this they call this machine the go home machine
but it's basically like a mechanical version
of Madame web that sends people back to their
universes of origin by using their DNA it looks
like they're demonstrating it using a version of
the Rhino who's based on one that wears a rhino's
suit Spider-Man 2099 then narrates his backstory
I think the fluid he's injecting into himself
is just a futuristic healing device repairing
his wounds all the scenes on his monitors are just
scenes from earlier in the movie like The Spot the
Lego Spider-Man's Universe you notice when they're
going to see him spider Punk also starts stealing
bits from other machines in the room in order to
make Gwen's homemade wrist device that allows her
to travel the Multiverse when she uses it to
escape and put her team together so the whole
idea here is that going up into this spider Punk
believed this whole time that things would play
out this way like oh yeah they're definitely going
to try to escape they're gonna need some help so
I'm going to build this Rich device to help them
they want to make it seem like he doesn't have
any plans but really spider Punk is playing this
four-dimensional chess game he also tells miles
that he doesn't want to be on the team like no
you don't want this you should make your own team
which is a reference to the team they put together
at the end of the movie you don't want their wrist
watch you should build your own as he's building
his own risk device to give to Gwen Stacy the
whole idea with this version of Spider-Man 2099
though is that he tried to recreate his family the
same way the kingpid did during the first movie
using the Multiverse like he traveled to another
Universe just like Kingpin searched the Multiverse
to find a version of his family that was alive but
a Nexus event was caused destroying that entire
reality that's why he thinks he needs to protect
the can of the official timeline the way that
things are going on like the sacred timeline the
way that he sees it Peter B Parker comes back with
his new daughter based on May Day Parker from the
comics she was born with his Spider-Man powers and
when she gets older in the comics she becomes a
version of Spider-Woman during the movie he builds
her a web shooter that looks like a child's toy
and she wears a baby hat that's knitted to look
like a Spider-Man mask like a baby Bonnet that
is a Spider-Man mask the way that Spider-Man 2099
explains the Canon theory of the spider-verse is
basically like the Loki explainer for how Nexus
events works in the timeline when he calls it
the web of life and Destiny that's right out of
the spider-verse comics but in the movie Universe
miles is the one who calls it the spider verse
for the first time there's a bunch of Easter eggs
in the different universes that they show too the
first one is from the old animated series showing
the original spider bite there's a bunch more ones
depicting events from the classic Comics including
the Venom symbiote suit like this is a bunch
of versions of Eddie Brock Venom this is Peter
B Parker watching his Uncle Ben die this is Manga
versus Spider-Man most of the other versions here
where they show all the Uncle Ben's dying are
versions that you saw earlier in the movie The
Event ASM 90 is a reference to Amazing Spider-Man
90 where basically what he says happens plays out
a version of Gwen Stacy's father Captain Stacy
died trying to protect someone and Spider-Man
was blamed for it we see the Andrew Garfield Cameo
scene from The Amazing Spider-Man movie watching
his version of Captain Stacy dye most of these are
the ones also depict each of the main characters
histories but done in the comic book style like
this is Spider-Man throwing away his costume from
the comics but it's spider Punk Instead This is
Jessica Drew's backstory but done in a comic book
visual style the wedding is from Peter B Parker's
marriage to his MJ after the events of the first
movie but it's done in the style of the classic
Spider-Man Mary Jane marriage in the comics they
have the Tobey Maguire Spider-Man Cameo scene
from the events of his first Spider-Man movie
The Universe hears from spectacular Spider-Man
he even has guest speaking lines like Josh Keaton
recorded new dialogue for it later when they all
walk up to listen to the rest of the speech this
is also Spider-Man Unlimited from that TV show
I didn't spot Spider-Man from the 90s animated
series but I think that he's in here too they did
pretty much every main version of Spider-Man from
every medium that's ever had a version of
Spider-Man did the big chase scene with the
most epic Spider-Man pointing meme ever I don't
know how they're going to Top This meme scene
the burger and fries are designed to look like
Spider-Man 2099 is also a Burger King campaign
they're doing in real life for the movie you
can actually go buy spider-verse burgers at
Burger King right now during the therapy session
the whole joke is that he's getting therapy for
the death of his Uncle Ben the therapist I think
is played by yorma tacon because he's supposed
to be in the movie He's also part of the Lonely
Island in real life with Andy Samberg who plays
a version of Ben Reilly miles rides Widow saying
Ohio silver from Lone Ranger while he's attacked
by the werewolf Spider-Man I don't remember if
this Spider Woman in the wheelchair is from the
comics or if she is new but he also gets attacked
by the monkey version of Spider-Man who is from
the comics when he's running through the gym too
he goes to a montage of a bunch of Spider-Man's
original comic book villains from The Sinister
Six like these are all classic versions of the
characters but the interesting thing is they have
an Alfred Molina Dr Octopus Cameo seen here it's
just his voice in The Voice line is actually
taken from the events of Spider-Man no way home
hello Peter so sort of like this amalgam Easter
egg of the original version of Dr Octopus from the
comics with the Alfred Molina version but also the
MCU movies in Spider-Man no way home I think this
is meant to be a joke on the Spider-Man homecoming
fairy save and Toby Maguire's train scene and
even though there are billions of versions
of Spider-Man and this I've already talked
about spider cat he's from the Miles Morales PS4
game but the other literal and metaphorical big
thing in the trailer is the version of spider
Rex they're actually doing a version of spider
Rex if you didn't read the spider-verse comics
spider Rex is just a version of Spider-Man from
a prehistoric Earth in an alternate universe that
got struck by a meteorite with a bunch of alien
spiders and that's how they got their powers
but it gets a little bit weirder the origin
story those characters on that prehistoric Earth
planet his original main villain is a pterodon
version of Green Goblin called noranosorman which
is a play on Norman Osborne but they were both in
each other's bodies the meteor strike caused
their minds to switch bodies and gave them
powers during the the wide shot when they have
many versions of the character this is meant to
be Metro boomin's big Cameo scene too he did a
bunch of music for the movie but they actually
turned him into a version of the character not
from the comics like this is original to the
movie but he's the one with the joke about not
having anywhere to run there's nowhere to run so
my bad everybody there was somewhere to run like I
said when miles uses his Venom Stinger ability to
suck the energy out of Spider-Man 2099's suit and
then use it to blow him back I think that's meant
to be foreshadowing for one of the ways that he'll
use in a more powerful way to de-power the spot
the miles escapes using the get home device except
it detects the spider's DNA that bit him sending
him to its Universe number 42 in that Universe
the color palette is way darker everything but
the whole tone the vibe of everything is way
darker just because it's meant to be a universe
where things went very badly because of what
happened because the spider that was supposed to
turn someone into Spider-Man in this universe like
this universe version of Miles Morales didn't wind
up biting this Miles because it came to another
universe and bit the other miles and what wound
up happening is that Earth 42 version of Miles
Morales goes dark and becomes a version of the
prowler taking the mantle from his uncle Aaron
Davis and in that Universe miles's father is the
one who's killed in the line of duty because there
is no Spider-Man to stop a lot of the criminals he
sees a mural in the place where he drew one for
his uncle Aaron like oh no it was my father that
was the one that died in this universe when they
discover the truth that Aaron Davis captures and
straps miles to a punching bag it's meant to be a
parallel to the first movie when Miles Morales did
the same thing to Peter B Parker when they first
met because his skills have gotten so much better
and because of what happened in that original
scene in the first movie with Peter B Parker
easily escaping his trap tied to the bag they
might have a similar scene with this version of
Miles Morales now much better at being Spider-Man
with his powers escaping the same type of way
lesson number one kid don't
watch the mouth watch the hands
blame the spot for everything that's going bad in
the movie they and his part of the story in the
movie with a scene of him discovering his Earth
42 self as the prowler who makes it seem like he's
going to kill miles as revenge for the death of
his father in this universe like how dare you take
this for me take my father from me even though
like I said it's not miles's fault like miles
is trying to win over this alternate version of
himself and Aaron Davis like you have to free me
because I have to stop the spot because the spot
is threatening all of reality in the movie The
Spot is kind of like a version of the beyonders
during Secret Wars he wants to basically erase the
entire Multiverse and remake it in his own image
while this is going on with Miles spider-gwen also
escapes the spider Society base with Hobie brown
spider Punk's help gives her a homemade cobbled
together webwear wristwatch allowing her to
open portals across the Multiverse which she
uses to go to Miles Morales real Universe tell
his parents some of what happened not everything
like she doesn't outright tell them that he's a
version of Spider-Man and about what's happening
with the spot in the Spy fighter war with the
spider Society Gwen then uses her wrist device
to collect her own side team of Spider-Man made
up of their team from the first movie in addition
to MayDay Parker who's still with Peter B Parker
in Spider-Man India Penny Parker Spider-Man Noir
spider ham all come back from the first movie and
spider Gwen takes them to Earth 42 to rescue Miles
Morales while this is also happening the spot who
at this point is consumed enough dark energy from
different Universe versions of the super collider
giving him the power of gray to affect reality in
a much bigger scale travels to miles morales's
original Universe claiming earlier that he was
going to take everything from miles and they want
you to think because of the longer Uncle Ben death
Montage early in the movie the captain Stacy death
Montage where there's this big talk about how
they're always supposed to die in every Universe
giving each version of Spider-Man their tragic
origin story they want you to think that because
in miles's Universe his father just became captain
of the police this means the spot will kill him
but big plot point in the movie is that because of
miles's unique accident that made him Spider-Man
he can change the cannon like the way that things
were supposed to happen and it won't destroy
all of reality because spider Gwen essentially
does the same thing in her Universe her father
Captain Stacy quits his job as Captain he isn't
killed off like was supposed to happen according
to Spider-Man 2099 and her universe is totally
fine like oh you can change things and it will be
okay and they end the movie with Gwen running into
the portal to Earth 42 and the message just reads
to be continue dot dot dot in the title teaser for
Spider-Man beyond the spider verse which is part
two of across the spider verse sort of like their
Empire Strikes Back Avengers Infinity War part 1
Downer ending where you know the story is going
to pick up with a year almost immediately where
they left off right now beyond the spider verse
is supposed to come out next year I don't know if
they're going to delay it or if they're going to
be any changes to that there's also reports that
we'll see some of the spider-verse characters
crossover in live action during Avengers 6 Secret
Wars we'll see about that at but they also just
announced that they're developing a live-action
Miles Morales Spider-Man movie and a spider Gwen
spin-off movie with Haley Steinfeld let me know
if you spotted any other Easter eggs or references
that I didn't mention in the video there were
so many you could watch the movie a bunch more
times and still find new stuff all do more
Spider-Man beyond the spider-verse videos soon
and let me know if you have any special requests
for spider-verse or Spider-Man bonus videos in the
comments everyone click here for my Spider-Man
across the spider-verse ending and post credit
scene video and click here for that new Spider-Man
4 live-action Miles Morales announcement thank you
so much for watching everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!